la page d'un voilier au large de
perros-guirec quatre jeunes scouts sont
morts un plaisancier porté disparu
l'imprudent sans doute à l'origine du
drame
tour de france richard virenque et huit
coureurs de l'équipe festina sont en
garde à vue les policiers ont également
perquisitionné l'hôtel de l'équipe
hollandaise pvm
entreprise publique aérospatiale se
marie avec matra haute technologie
naissance d'un géant de l'aéronautique
française en partie privatisée
plus de 43 degrés à l'ombre à new york
la canicule remonte du sud vers le nord
est des états unis en faisant des
victimes au passage sur les planches de
deauville une voix en or celle d'al
jarreau qui donnait hier soir un récital
à l'occasion du festival de jazz
madame monsieur bonsoir un drame au
large de perros guirec en bretagne hier
après midi à l'occasion d'une sortie en
mer cette jeune scout temps en vacances
dans la région et qui avaient pris place
à bord d'un petit voilier ont fait
naufrage en est malheureusement certains
de la mort de quatre d'entre eux et un
autre jeune homme qui leur avaient porté
secours est encore considéré pour
l'instant comme disparus
les raisons de cet accident sont encore
floues mais visiblement l'imprudence y
est pour beaucoup
les adolescents étaient seuls à bord de
l'embarcation la mer était mauvaise et
l'alertent m'a été donné que très tard
dans la soirée d'hier
olivier piou michel hilaire reportage
l'arrivée des corbillards à la chapelle
ardente dressée dans un gymnase de
perros guirec en fin d'après midi les
corps de trois des quatre jeunes scouts
décédées sont revenus de rennes où avait
eu lieu leur autopsie
les premières familles et leurs proches
sont arrivées presque au même moment
cet adolescent scouts avaient quitté
port béni hier matin pour rallier perros
guirec à bord d'un petit dériveur
homologué pour six personnes seulement
le drame s'est joué vers 14 heures
lorsque leur embarcation a chaviré à
plusieurs reprises mais l'alertent l'a
semble-t-il était donnée que tardivement
par le directeur du groupe l'a fait
prévenir le croise porcel dit-il à 17h
le contact que j'ai eu avec l'officier
le cas cette nuit faisait état d'une
information du cross corsen à un tour le
22 heures
guy allart générer une divergence
notable que je cherche à éclaircir
la mer était particulièrement mauvaise
il hier avec des vents de 60 kilomètres
heure ce qui rend d'autant plus
inexplicable cette sortie en mer c'est
vrai que le vent s'est levé à un moment
vent et même quelques petites rafales et
je pense que
effectivement prendre la mer dans des
conditions c'est pas toujours
souhaitable d'ores et déjà l'enquêté
fait apparaître une accumulation de
fautes de la part des adultes
responsables de ces jeunes
quelques jours après un premier incident
dans un autre groupe de scouts dans le
sud de la france
le drame d'hier met en lumière les
difficultés d'encadrement de ces camps
d'été pour adolescents le directeur de
la colonie un prêtre a d'ailleurs été
longuement entendu par les enquêteurs
cet après-midi et le procureur de la
république n'exclut pas qu'il puisse
être mis en garde à vue dans les heures
qui viennent
les victimes sont originaires de mantes
la jolie en région parisienne elle
appartenait à un mouvement dissident du
scoutisme français une association
intégristes catholiques qui avait pris
ses quartiers d'été à perros-guirec
ludovic fossat raymond chappard avec ses
rituels
la vie continue et aujourd'hui à la base
bretonne des scouts marins comme si de
rien n'était ici il n'ya pas
d'encadrement ou le moins possible
l'autonomie des enfants est mise en
avant par les adhérents de cette
association proche des milieux
catholiques intégristes
ça c'est normal des adolescents autonome
même dans le cas d'une sortie en mer
voilà qui ne choquait pas ce matin les
familles des victimes présentes au siège
de l'association
les mesures de sécurité à votre avis ont
été finis bien sûr c'est à dire c'est un
regrettable accident
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient eu de
défaillance et encore moins de faute de
qui que ce soit en fin de matinée les
familles sont partis rejoindre leurs
enfants présents en bretagne non
reconnus par les scouts de france cette
association regroupe 200 à 300 adhérents
en france
leur différence est mise en avant par
des insignes et par une certaine idée du
scoutisme
le scout et chats de sa foi lui soumet
toute sa vie le premier le scout et fils
de france est bon citoyen le troisième
le devoir du secours commencent à la
maison c'est pas ça un rassemblement à
ce moment c'est une sonnerie
tout le monde s'emballe l'association
reprend ses activités le tour de france
c'est encore dans tous ses états
aujourd'hui avec l'audition de trois
responsables de l'équipe hollandaise tvm
qui toujours sur le tour elle nous y
reviendrons dans un instant mais d'abord
la mise en garde à vue de neuf coureurs
de l'équipe festina dont richard
virenque interrogé depuis le début cet
après midi dans les locaux de la police
à lyon
virginie fichet et guillaume faudra
réfugier derrière des vitres teintées
l'équipe krystina au grand complet
pénètre dans les locaux du srpj lyonnais
il est 14 heures les coureurs doivent
être entendus comme simples témoins mais
peu après leur arrivée coup de théâtre
richard vers un quai ses coéquipiers
sont placés en garde à vue
c'est pas une mesure
impliquant une idée quelconque de
culpabilité que c'est l'opinion publique
qui croire que la garde à vue signifie
prise en compte d'une culpabilité
c'est une mesure qui est destiné à
conférer des droits à la personne
entendue qui demeure témoins à leur
arrivée à lyon en fin de matinée les
cyclistes avaient retrouvé leur avocat
les visages étaient fermés
l'heure n'était pas aux commentaires
l'opposition mais les neuf coureurs
étaient encore confiant la garde à vue
il ne s'y attendait pas les coureurs
suisses de l'équipe avait même exigé la
garantie de ressortir livre de l'hôtel
de police
garante et que j'avais c'était qu'il n'y
aurait pas de mise en examen
et c'est tout et actuellement on en est
là mais chez viens et je vous avoue
honnêtement que j'ai bien l'intention ce
soir de repartir avec les courants tôt
ce matin michel grau et miguel moreno
tous deux directeurs sportifs de festina
ont eux aussi été placés en garde à vue
avec leur responsable logistique joëlle
chabry relâchés quelques heures plus
tard joël chapiron et ce soir le seul
festina libre de tout mouvement
parallèlement à cet interrogatoire on a
appris aujourd'hui que la justice belle
sort est en possession de documents
médicaux prouvant noir sur blanc que les
coureurs de l'équipe festina était bel
et bien doper le soigneur de l'équipe
hollywood par qui le scandale est arrivé
demande à être une nouvelle fois entendu
par la police
éventuellement pour faire d'autres
révélations caroline marque
l'étau se resserre autour d'eric rykart
le médecin de l'équipe festina mise en
examen cette fois les accusations
proviennent de la justice belge qui
s'intéresse depuis plusieurs mois à ces
activités
une perquisition fut effective et le
docteur et cartes ou une vingtaine de
dossiers de coureurs de l'équipe festina
furent saisis une analyse de ces
dossiers pourraient faire apparaître
l'utilisation des produits et pau le
pays-haut un produit dopant qui
apparaîtrait sous forme cryptée dans
l'ordinateur portable du médecin le juge
de gauche se dit prêt à communiquer le
dossier aux juges lillois
a lille c'est à sa demande que oui les
voûtes le soigneur de l'équipe festina a
été réentendu par le juge
il nie toute importation de produits
dopants juste leur transport
il rappelle qu'il agissait sur ordre
c'est sous la contrainte qu'il a agi et
sans l'ombre d'un profit comme ils
disent en souriant pas même un petit
voyage comme certains en parlent
en contrepartie de ce transport de
produits de poing exclusivement
conserver une place payée en tout et
pour tout
quatorze mille francs par mois pour cet
homme que l'on contraignait à conduire
sans permis de conduire qu'il a dit
demain où il y [ __ ] répétera au juge
ses déclarations mais cette fois en
présence de bruno roussel et d'eric art
le soigneur pourrait être remise en
liberté à l'issue de cette confrontation
sur place à lyon ne rejoigne en tirer
kurt et thierry bonsoir la garde à vue
des coureurs de l'équipe festina se
poursuit à l'heure qu'il est
effectivement elle se poursuit il faut
bien dire que depuis 16 heures
il ne s'est franchement pas passé grand
chose aux alentours du palais juste du
palais de depardon de l'hôtel de police
ici à lyon
en revanche on sait que les neuf
coureurs de l'équipe festina haute été
assez surpris de se retrouver placé en
garde à vue il était venu ici clamé leur
innocence déclaré qu'il était victime du
système
mais les enquêteurs ont estimé qu'ils
avaient des questions forte intéressante
à leur poser tout d'abord sur la caisse
noire et les fameux 400 mille francs
évoquée par leur directeur bruno roussel
qui dit at il dit servais devait servir
à acheter des produits dopants
ensuite sur la quantité de pétrole
utilisé si bien sûr les coureurs
connaissent utiliser avoir utilisé de le
paix aux cartes 400 doses ont été saisis
à la frontière je vous le rappelle est
pour les enquêteurs c'est 400 d'eau
semble bon
pour l'approvisionnement de la seule
équipe festina ils veulent savoir si par
là il n'y aurait pas l'approvisionnement
également d'autres équipes
merci thierry sur le tour la journée de
repos a été marquée ce matin par une
nouvelle intervention de la police qui a
perquisitionné l'hôtel occupée par
l'équipe tv est ma majorité hollandaise
suspecté dans une affaire similaire à
celle de festina mais qui remonte au
mois de mars dernier trois dirigeants de
l'équipe ont été interpellés ils ont
d'ailleurs été relâché ce soir olivier
galzi jean-pierre pasteur et de 2 8
heures ce matin la deuxième perquisition
du tour de france est en cours à l'hôtel
de l'équipe tv m des enquêteurs de la pj
de toulouse et de mètres sont envahis
les lieux à la recherche de produits
dopants tout sera fouillé en présence du
directeur sportif de l'équipe
il passera un dernier coup de téléphone
avant d'être emmenés en compagnie du
médecin de l'équipe et d'un mécanicien
les trois hommes ont été placés en garde
à vue au commissariat de pamiers est
rejoint dans l'après midi par le
directeur sportif adjoint
saisi une valise médical et des
poubelles contenant des médicaments
usagers dont on ignore encore la nature
en attendant l'identification de ces
produits les enquêteurs interrogeront
les quatre membres de l'équipe sur les
événements de mars dernier
un mécanicien de chez pvm avait alors
été arrêté au volant d'une voiture
chargée de p o
un produit dopant mais à l'époque le
parquet n'avait pas donné suite
aujourd'hui les coureurs de tvm ont
préféré fuir notre caméra leur première
journée de repos portait bien mal son
nom
cette deuxième intervention policière
sur le tour de france a fait l'effet ici
d'un véritable électrochoc
hier festina aujourd'hui tvm et ces
mêmes questions qui reviennent les
produits dopants intercepté il ya
quelques mois et est il destiné aux
coureurs
l'encadrement de l'équipe était-il
informé de ce trafic
pour l'heure les quatre personnes
interpellées continuer à répondre aux
questions et nul ne peut dire ce soir si
elles pourront reprendre la course
demain
voilà je voulais dit à l'instant un
certain nombre de ses dirigeants de
l'équipe tm ont été relâchés par la
police
il faut évidemment s'interdire de
généraliser et prétendre que tous les
coureurs cyclistes sont dopés mais en
enquêtant aujourd'hui dans la ville de
repos du tour de france
on s'aperçoit que l'on retrouve un
nombre inquiétant de médicaments
suspects dans l'environnement des hôtels
où séjournent certaines équipes olivier
caroff olivier galzi jean pierre basque
chaque matin les poubelles sont les
seules traces laissées par les coureurs
des poubelles qui en disent parfois long
sur ce que l'on ne voit jamais l'autre
visage du sport seringue perfusion
ampoules la pharmacie pour aller plus
vite sur les boîtes le nom des coureurs
et parmi ces boîtes parfois des produits
interdits comme ces de corticoïdes le
bain telle en 4 et le sait les stones
chrono dose les corticoïdes ce
c'est partie de la grande famille des
médicaments anti-inflammatoires et puis
ça peut être dévoyé parce que ça permet
de retirer certaines douleurs on peut
augmenter la charge d'entraînement pour
explication nous avons ramené les
poubelles à son propriétaire
l'équipe italienne à 6 traduction latine
un esprit sain dans un corps sain le
médecin de l'équipe qui nous a affirmé
ne pas prescrire ces produits n'a pas
dans un premier temps reconnu sa
poubelle
peut-être que là la poubelle plus belles
îles hautes et la poubelle ou à haute
pression ni l'habitude et de choses
après il y avait les noms des coureurs
de suite des coureurs alors peut-être
vous pourrez utiliser pour rire au sol
j'ai pas utiliser le binntal à noter que
l'essentiel était un soigneur et j'ai
pas voulu dire quelle soigneur utilise
parce que
c'est une tradition du cyclisme que
beaucoup de souvenirs utilisent ce
produit est trop mou scolaire en 36
colère et comme médecins nous on s'est
toujours fait la guerre à ça maintenant
je fais la figure que j'ai utilisé j'ai
pas voulu dire je pense mais je peux
promettre en soigneront l'équipe en
position ou le soigneur réapparaît sur
le devant de la scène les goûts vous des
coureurs
ces personnages que personne ne semble
contrôler même pas les médecins dans
cette poubelle c'est vrai les autres
produits ne sont pas interdits pourtant
les experts que nous avons contacté
affirme qu'il serait un complément
parfait pour le pays ou l'hormone de
croissance
ces géants du dopage dont tout le monde
parle ici mais que l'on ne voit jamais
de le pays
ce médecin suisse veut bien en montrer
daniel blanc s'occupe entre autres de
richard virenque
la star de festina pour lui prescrire ce
produit dopant ne pose aucun problème de
conscience
à mon avis quelques fois on protégerait
plus un sportif en lui donnant un petit
peu dépôts qui lui permet d'avoir un
taux d'hémoglobine normal que les vitres
est de s'épuiser d'être malade faire des
infections à répétition que de ne rien
lui donner et l'ont aidé un trucs
invraisemblables un discours
inacceptable pour bien des praticiens
médecins sens et un médecin raisonnable
qui connaît l'entraînement qui connaît
la physiologie l'entraînement qui
connaît la programmation de
l'entraînement qu'est ce qu'il va faire
il va demander aux sportifs d'en faire
un petit peu moins pour récupérer
naturellement si au contraire ce médecin
se met à lui donner des produits pour
masquer la fatigue qui peut commencer à
le gagner pour le faire continuer à
s'entraîner et à participer à des
compétitions malgré les signes évidents
de fatigue et d'insuffisance variés
qu'il peut avoir ce médecin est un
criminel
plusieurs cas de morts suspectes
d'anciens cyclistes sont attribués par
les scientifiques à la consommation de p
ô le dopage dans le milieu sportif et
précisément du cyclisme n'est pas une
nouveauté malheureusement son histoire
est jalonnée d'accidents et de drames et
aujourd'hui la pression de l'argent des
sponsors ne fait que s'accentuer il faut
jour après jour réaliser l'exploit qui
mettra l équipe en vedette avec cette
question centrale le tour de france
n'est-il pas devenu trop dur
des athlètes qui ne sont tout de même
pas aidé sur florent gautreau à
l'emprunt ça sent bon la lavande et les
vacances au soleil
l'équipe cofidis se repose l'heure est à
la galerie jeanne il sait que ça c'est
un cuissard jaune pour ton futur maillot
jaune gardien jusqu'à ce que je le pense
vraiment ok je garde bobbie jay leach
deuxième au classement général en a rêvé
le rendait bien la fée maillot jaune
pendant deux journées
le nordiste peut savourer et surtout
souffler le stress la pression
médiatique et bien sûr la fatigue
physique sont émoussées le jour de repos
tombe à pic
mais au fait une seule journée de répit
est ce bien raisonnable
pas beaucoup mais
en italie non mais c'est les deux jeunes
coureurs n'ont pas connu ces tours des
années 50 où il y avait deux journées de
repos
c'était le cas en 51 mais à l'époque il
y avait 24 étapes contre 21 aujourd'hui
al'inverse en 62 les coureurs n'avaient
eu droit à aucun jour de répit pendant
les trois semaines du tour de france
alors un jour deux jours ou pas de jour
du tout difficile de se faire une
religion
j'ai connu des tours de france avec deux
journées de repos même pour ma part ça
ça cassait le rythme et j'étais pas très
favorable mais peut-être que d'autres
coureurs et c'était pas qui se roule
beaucoup plus vite peut-être que de
jeunes et propose ce serait peut-être
salutaire salutaire sans doute pour
certains coureurs qui arrivent déjà
fatigués en juillet la saison est
harassante et le tour toujours plus
dures 2.3.4 cole pourquoi pas cinq cols
on pourra peut-être même jean le cam et
bétonne venir le désir de tout le monde
qui cherchent un exploit qui a besoin de
voir l'athlète oms ont subi mais
beaucoup pour l'organisme le rythme est
telle que les coureurs ne s'arrête
jamais
la preuve même le jour de repos ils
doivent remonter sur le vélo
le gouvernement quant à lui suit le
dossier pratiquement au jour le jour et
cet après midi encore marie george
buffet la ministre de la jeunesse et des
sports a estimé une nouvelle fois qu'il
fallait aller jusqu'au bout crever l
abcès pour répondre à l'inquiétude de
nombreux éducateurs et du mouvement
sportif en général marie georges buffet
et contre le dopage se soucient plus où
me amateurs et notamment vers les jeunes
sportifs il faut développer une campagne
d'information de formation je dirais des
sportifs de l'encadrement
il faut poursuivre les contrôles parce
que ça permet quand même d'être en
alerte et certainement d'éviter à
d'autres jeunes de consommer des
produits dopants
et puis il faut mobiliser l'ensemble du
mouvement sportif y compris le petit
club de cette question les bénévoles
nous appelle à l'aide que cette question
va les aider
et maintenant on nous retrouvons sur la
route du tour alexandre kara bonsoir
vous avez vécu bonsoir milieu des
coureurs et de la caravane cette
nouvelle journée à rebondissements
comment l'at ont vécu sur place ou une
journée un peu particulière c'est vrai
oui si on espérait prendre un repos bien
mérité après des journées difficiles
tant sportivement que médiatiquement et
c'est vrai ce matin cette tranquillité a
été en quelque sorte sa beauté parle
annonce de ces interpellations dans
l'équipe tv m
alors il faut dire ici les autres les
équipes sont éparpillés dans des hôtels
autour de tarascon d'où partirent à
l'étape de demain et c'est vrai les
coureurs ont appris tardivement la
nouvelle on a croisé laurent jalabert
tout à l'heure qui nous faisait qui ne
voulait pas commenter les coureurs
n'aime pas tellement parler des autres
coureurs sur ce genre d'affaires est en
revanche nous a quand même confié que
l'ambiance n'était pas très bonne dans
le peloton
alors c'est vrai chez les coureurs on
espérait qu'après l'exclusion de
l'équipe festina tout ça serait terminée
que enfin le sport reprend dressé de ses
droits sur cette affaire et ce soir
c'est vrai que cet espoir a fait long
feu
la nouvelle a été tenue secrète jusqu'au
dernier moment la fusion de l'entreprise
publique aérospatiale et d'une filiale
du groupe lagardère matra haute
technologie qui donne naissance un géant
français d'aéronautique quatrième groupe
mondial
c'est également une privatisation
partielle puisque l'état conservera
moins de 50% dans le capital de cette
nouvelle entreprise pascal golomer et
pierre moscovitch
ils étaient bien peu ces derniers jours
à prédire une telle poignée de main un
tel mariage entre le groupe public
aérospatiale et le groupe privé
matra haute technologie mais salariés
des chaînes de montage d'airbus eux
mêmes à toulouse ont appris la nouvelle
ce matin en lisant la presse ce qu'il
fallait s'y attendre
ne serait ce que pour le développement
parce qu'on peut pas faire tout tout
seul c'est pas possible ça aboutira
certainement à des licenciements
tourné façon ou d'une autre mais voilà
on va être les meilleurs et je pense que
ça ne peut
donner du goût moi je dis bravo l'état
restera actionnaire majoritaire mais
avec désormais moins de 50% du capital
c'est donc bien une privatisation
d'aérospatiale le groupe lagardère
détiendra 30 à 33% des actions 3 à 4%
étant réservés aux salariés
le nouvel ensemble génère un chiffre
d'affaires de 80 milliards de francs et
emploie 56 mille salariés les salariés
qui fabrique à la fois des avions des
hélicoptères des missiles des fusées et
des satellites
c'est désormais le premier pôle européen
le 4e mondial dans l'aéronautique et
l'armement
c'est un moyen extrêmement efficace pour
faire face avec concurrence mondiale
telle qu'elle existe et en matière
d'emploi c'est de nature à développer
l'emploi puisque douleur davantage de
force ça vous permettra d'aller
conquérir davantage de marchés un
regroupement créateurs d'emplois donc
les syndicats préfèrent rester prudents
permettez nous d'en douter
l'expérience nous a démontré que
particulièrement dans le domaine de la
défense aujourd'hui nous subissons quand
même la réduction des crédits affectés à
ce secteur
mais derrière ce mariage c'est tout un
jeu d'alliances avec les autres
constructeurs européens qui se profile
pour lutter enfin armes égales contre
les géants américain boeing mcdonnell
douglas en tête en corse les gendarmes
ont découvert aujourd'hui une cache
d'explosifs contenant 375 kg de dynamite
des explosifs dangereux dans la
fabrication remonte aux années 70 la
dynamite a été découverte dans une cave
en haute-corse antoine de menton ancien
trésorier du parti républicain mise en
examen pour le blanchiment d'une somme
de 5 millions de francs pour le compte
du parti de françois léotard dont le nom
est apparu dans cette affaire à
l'occasion d'une demande de prêt banque
l'éducation nationale renouvelle cette
année pendant les vacances et amplifiera
l'année prochaine
en période scolaire l'ouverture des
établissements les jours de repos
il s'agit d'offrir aux enfants qui n'ont
pas forcément la possibilité de partir
en vacances l'occasion de se livrer un
certain nombre d'activités encadrées par
des éducateurs en toute sécurité donc
pour les parents
cet été 190 établissements scolaires ne
fermeront pas leurs portes reportage
jean bernard schmidt et jean louis malle
d'ordinaire en plein mois de juillet un
collège sévit plus de cours plus de
profs plus d'élèves
enfin apparemment
ici durant toute une partie de l'été
l'école reste ouvert chaque jour une
centaine d'enfants vient au collège pour
y participer à des activités
l'histoire de quitter un peu l'univers
de la rue cabot de ya même pas de cash
de foot de reuil donne des poubelles big
honnêtement que c'est à dire que c'est
un collage de penser qu'ils ont 20 ans
tout de suite que s'élancera dans un
sens de loisirs il ya tant d'activités
au programme musique sport cuisine
informatique ou jeux de société ce sont
en tout quinze animateurs emplois jeunes
ou professeurs en vacances qui accueille
les enfants et suscite parfois des
vocations
et moi mon but c'est de leur apprendre
et puis j'ai essayé de leur faire aimer
le métier de la cuisine de façon à ce
que plus tard je leur explique que
justement plus tard le métier de la
cuisine c'est quelque chose qu'il y
avait fort mal de débouchés
classé en zone sensible le collège jean
vilar est situé au coeur d'une cité jugé
très difficile
l'ouverture de l'établissement pendant
l'été calmer les esprits et rassure les
parents les enfants vont quelque part
ils vont à l'école et verts qui veut
faire quelque chose il faut pas de
bêtises pendant ce temps là pour les
enseignants pas question de créer une
annexe du club méditerranée l'école
ouverte
c'est un pari sur l'avenue voit la
rentrée de septembre
l'année prochaine on va avoir des
contacts complètement différent avec les
enfants qui ont participé à l'école
ouverte et on va peut-être même pouvoir
se servir de ces mêmes enfants en tant
qu'ambassadeur c'est une expression que
j'ai du vent pour permettre aux aussi
devenir et d'être se socialiser être
responsable sésame pour cette opération
le collège reçoit de l'état 30 mille
francs par semaine une aide précieuse
pour lutter contre l'oisiveté et
favoriser la paix sociale dans le
quartier gérard depardieu devant le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles ce
matin victime d'un accident de moto au
mois de mai dernier avec 2 grammes et ni
d'alcool dans le sang
l'acteur a reconnu ses torts devant la
justice et la nuit qu'il devait être
sanctionné il a écopé en conséquence de
trois mois de prison avec sursis et une
suppression de permis pendant 15 mois
chose promise chose due zinedine zidane
a rendu visite hier à ses amis de son
quartier de marseille la castellane là
où il est né là où il a grandi
c'est en toute discrétion que le
champion du monde a voulu faire cette
visite est aujourd'hui tout le quartier
en parle encore avec des trémolos dans
la voix
yannick à 6 24 heures après l'événement
ils ont encore un peu de mal à revenir
sur terre
la boucherie se transforme en galerie
d'exposition photos mes souvenirs sont
inoubliables la visite de l'enfant de la
cité champion du monde de football j'ai
fait pas mal de photos je m'y attendais
pas du tout j - jv voir une foule pas
possible et j'ai réussi à prendre
quelques photos jeu très complet et si
personne pas les la jouer le jeu à tout
le moins des autographes des photos
gentil et bien sûr les enfants étaient
au centre de la fête des autographes des
bisous des poignées de main par
centaines oui déjà de jouer la coupe du
monde et c'est un chien merci d'y rester
cinq minutes et pour moi cinq minutes
c'est beaucoup d'heures
son image est omniprésente mais zidane
n'a passé que quarante-cinq minutes hier
à la castellane visite au centre social
au club de foot de la cité certains
auraient aimé une grande fête mais le
footballeur a préféré une incursion
impromptue retrouver un petit peu chez
lui et être être avec les siens donc on
a été obligé de faire ça un peu à huis
clos et donc tout ça il ya ceux qui
n'ont vraiment mais vraiment pas de
chance mais avec un peu de patience et
d'attention ou madame la buraliste ne
ratera pas les futurs champions de la
castellane
si vous voulez revivre la coupe du monde
de football aux éditions michel lafon
sort demain un récit de notre confrère
patrice randle et un et deux et trois
zéro le score de la finale contre le
brésil 100 jours dans les coulisses du
mondial 98
l'actualité internationale troisième
jour de fouilles sans succès
malheureusement à beyrouth pour tenter
de retrouver le corps de l'otage
français michel seurat à mort en
captivité 7 et en 1986 maryse burgot
patrick démunis
c'est aujourd'hui l'un des chantiers les
mieux protégés de la banlieue sud de
beyrouth
la police ne laisse pas ces personnes
c'est donc à l'abri des regards que les
pelleteuses fouilles la terre depuis
trois jours
déterminé à retrouver les restes de
michel seurat mort en captivité il ya
maintenant douze ans le chercheur
français aurait donc été enterrés ici
par ses ravisseurs
et c'est vraisemblablement dans
l'enchevêtrement de ces maisons il fut
détenu pendant plusieurs mois dans les
rues de beyrouth
on ne s'intéresse guère à cette affaire
qui mobilise pourtant autorités
françaises et libanaises récemment paris
a servi d'intermédiaire dans un échange
de corps de prisonniers entre israël et
le groupe hesbollah ce sont entre autres
ses bons offices qui permettent
aujourd'hui l'éventuel rapatriement du
corps de sera selon ce journaliste qui a
suivi de très près la sphère des otages
c'est ce contexte politique favorable
qui fait avancer aujourd'hui le dossier
douze ans après les faits
la france a fourni la logistique pour
cet échange elle a envoyé un avion qui a
transporté les restes du soldat
israélien et qui en échange rapporté au
liban les corps mais aussi les
prisonniers appartenant au hezbollah
d'un coup
c'est cela qui a créé ces bonnes pendant
ce temps une femme attend dans le
silence le résultat de ces tractations
diplomatiques
marie sereins les pousses de l'ex otage
est en ce moment ici à beyrouth avec ses
deux filles
et là quand nous lui avons parlé ce
matin mais elle ne souhaite pas pour
l'instant s'exprimer sur cette
douloureuse attente cette femme attend
depuis maintenant douze ans qu'on
veuille bien au moins lui rendre la
dépouille de son mari à elle et à ses
deux enfants
le tribunal de téhéran a condamné
aujourd'hui pour corruption le maire de
la capitale cinq ans de prison deux
millions de francs d'amendé assortis de
60 coups de fouet
la corruption a été établi mais il
s'agit également dans cette affaire
d'une lutte d'influencé entre le
président modéré mohammad khatami dont
le maire est un des alliés et les
conservateurs qui tiennent toujours en
mains l'assemblée nationale et les
rouages principaux de l'état le condamné
gholam hossein karbaschi a la
possibilité de faire appel de cette
sanction
les archives anglaises de la deuxième
guerre mondiale livre un nouveau secret
celui des attentats préparés contre
hitler à la fin de la guerre entre 44 et
45 et qui n'ont jamais reçu un début de
commencement londres eric monnet
s'ils avaient reçu l'ordre d'éliminer
physiquement adolf hitler à la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale les services
secrets britanniques auraient pu le
faire
il était près les archives de guerre
désormais public la teste et livrent les
différents scénarios possibles
un attentat contre le train du führer ou
une attaque de son nid d'aigle son refus
de berchtesgaden cartes photos schémas
tout est là scrupuleusement répertorie
des uniformes de ses 260 gardes du corps
et c'est ce jusqu aux habitudes hitler
sa balade quotidienne à pied seul à la
merci d'un tireur isolé où son goût pour
le thé au lait dans lequel un agent
secret aurait pu verser du kwazulu une
attaque à la grenade contre sa voiture
était envisageable
sinon envisagée car les services secrets
ne sont jamais passés à l'acte par peur
sans doute de fer d'un dictateur
vieillissant 1944 un marty au sein même
des services secrets il y avait un
étrange mélange entre des idées
brillantes et diabolique et des
réticences à les réaliser
pour les agents de sa majesté hitler
n'était pas la seule cible possible un
plan quelque peu fantaisiste prévoyait
même d'hypnotiser rudolph hess l'ancien
bras droit d'hitler pour qu'ils tuent de
ses mains amrich imlach le chef ss et
ses nouvelles archives rendu public ce
matin ont permis de faire bien d'autres
découvertes
on trouve aussi ici un registre des
goûts et perversions sexuelles des
anciens nazis
un travail qui devait permettre de
discréditer le troisième reich
de quoi nous faire rêver en ce mois de
juillet la canicule qui s'est abattue
sur les états unis elle remonte du sud
du texas vers le nord-est des etats-unis
on annonce pour aujourd'hui c'est le
début de la matinée à new york plus de
43 degrés à l'ombre sur place philippe
gassot l'amérique est en sueur prise
dans une vague de chaleur et l'on
transpire aussi
à manhattan à new york le thermomètre a
tutoyé les 40 degrés à l'ombre
bien entendu mais ça n'est pas le plus
difficile à supporter ce qui pèse sur
les épaules
c'est une humidité qui oscille entre 65
et 85 cents
ce qui rend laborieuse les activités
extérieures on est habitué par ici à
transporter sa boisson en général
gazeuses et sucrées mais par les temps
qui courent law for re a fait son
apparition
même si son prix semblent indexé sur le
tao jones à la bourse de wall street la
demie bouteille est vendu autour de 10
francs le commerce profite de l'aubaine
personne ne se plaint c'est la dure loi
de la canicule
ceux qui n'ont pas à se rendre sur leur
lieu de travail peuvent s'économiser
dans la verdure de central park
en attendant des jours meilleurs les
touristes qui on quittait une france
plutôt fraîche en ont pour leur argent
parce que la chaleur ça vous gêne en
tant que touriste 1
donc le touriste oui oui parce qu on
marche beaucoup parce qu'on est obligés
tu as toujours à l'extérieur trois coups
le maire d obésité
mais c'est le prix du voyage et de la
découverte
qu'est ce que vous faites pour vous
protéger de la chaleur on fait comme on
peut on voit beaucoup on s'est figé dans
les magasins et supermarchés
reprenons attendant pour le voir nos
boissons dans les restaurants vous aviez
l'idée qui faisait aussi chaud et déjà à
non absolument
on savait qu'ils allaient par chômeur
sport parce qu'un sonam times square en
ces mois d'été est certainement est
proportionnellement l'endroit le plus
peuplé du monde au cm² le célèbre
triangle connaît aujourd'hui une
relative désaffection le touriste ou
privilégient les centres commerciaux
ultra climatiser le service d'ordre
lui-même resserre les relève pour les
hommes et pour les chevaux après une
semaine de canicule les new-yorkais sont
peut être arrivés au bout de leur peine
la météo annonce pour ce soir une vague
d'air plus frais qui vient du canada
avec peut-être même quelques gouttes de
pluie
dans notre série les vacances des autres
et les plus originales
lille 2 hoult sur la mer du nord en
frise préau là bas à la frontière entre
l'allemagne et le danemark lille est
reliée au continent non pas par une
route mais par une voie ferrée c'est un
endroit très chic
même si l'eau y est très froid près de
gray on est loin de new york sur place
reportage d'olivier dernière les rails
seront posés sur la mer et toutes les
demi heures le train déversent des
dizaines de voitures des grosses des
moyennes des petites zulte c'est la côte
d'azur des allemands entrée payante pour
admirer le paysage
36 km de plage mais ici on réfléchit à
deux fois avant de mettre la tête sous
l'eau
juillet en mer du nord c'est la haute
saison le mois le plus chaud les
allemands adorent ça fait 30 ans qu'on
vient ici pour nous est le dieu de 80
ans cet idéal une plage de plusieurs
kilomètres de long est réservé aux
chiens qui préfèrent souvent rester bien
sage sur le sable la baignade
la douche froide devrait-on dire relève
de l'exploit ouais là juste pour une
journée il faut que j'en profite au
maximum on prend bien la température de
zulte sur ce bateau qui n'a qu'une
destination un banc de sable avec ses
phoques
il a juste un peu de vent la mer et à 16
degrés bref c'est le bonheur un bonheur
partagé par trois cent mille personnes
souvent prises au piège des routes
empruntées en temps normal par vingt
mille habitants
le vent qui décoiffe
la rudesse du climat les prix plus chers
que sur le continent repousse les
étrangers peu nombreux mais pas les
allemands
c'est vrai que si les prix sont 10% plus
cher que sur le continent à l'heure on
alterne entre pique nique et restaurants
le bris du mètre carré est plus cher
qu'à paris les maisons tout le même
style toit de chaume en parfait état
exotisme assuré avec cependant quelques
surprises pour le touriste qui vient ici
pour la première fois cette cuisine à
une odeur particulière
une odeur de choucroute qui fait la
fortune de ce restaurateur alsacien
installé ici depuis 15 ans
peu près 150 francs étonnant aussi ce
qu'a fait recouvert d'un tapis vert
pendant la guerre il servait d'abri de
bunkers pour les troupes
voilà la chambre à coucher des soldats
et là bas derrière c'était le gars al
photos d'époque
la page est tournée zulte est devenu
l'un des endroits les plus courus par
les allemands qui viennent passer leurs
vacances d'été ou d'hiver où il n'y a
pas grand chose à faire
les étés pluvieux les hivers rigoureux
c'est ce qui fait sans doute le charme
de cette île niché à plus de 600
kilomètres de berlin que l'on quitte ce
toujours en file indienne pare-choc
contre pare-choc
le festival de jazz de deauville
accueillait hier soir le chanteur
américain al jarreau dont le succès ne
s'est jamais démenti depuis plus de 20
ou 25 ans maintenant al jarreau c'est
avant tout une voix extraordinaire qui a
chanté est toutes les musiques et le
jazz bien entendu stéphane guez christ
au final le plus souvent on entre dans
l'univers d'al jarreau en tombant sous
le charme d'un de ses tubes indémodables
et derrière l'homme du show business on
découvre l'acrobate de la syllabe
le virtuose de l'arabesque vocale
en effet qu'à moi je crois que je suis
plutôt un homme de percussions actu bien
sûr quelques j'apprécie le bel canto
mais j'aime beaucoup les rythmes
sur scène al jarreau s'amuse toujours
autant après vingt ans d'une carrière
commencée sur les planches des jazz club
new yorkais
là il a acquis le goût de
l'improvisation le sens du spectacle
le studio parfois c'est impeut fabriquer
intercepté meilleure chose que j'ai
faite c'est devant un public débris
names are soit ils viennent avec leur
coeur de leurs yeux trop grand monsieur
de la musique noire américaine du jazz à
la pop music en flirtant avec le funk un
métissage qui a influencé les créateurs
durable
leur musique avec de la musique que je
fais la musique que george benson fait
celle d'herbie hancock ont apporté ce
capable de toutes les fantaisies vocales
al jarreau a surtout nos secrets de ses
chansons qui vibre comme des carrés
l'etna détenant en éruption le volcan
sicilien qui demeure en activité
permanente a connu des soubresauts
importants ces dernières 24 heures vous
loyer et qui pourtant ne représente
aucun signe de gravité ni de danger pour
les populations environnantes
même si l'aéroport de catane tout proche
qui se trouve au pied de l'etna a dû
être fermée hier toute la journée 24
heures conséquence d'une épaisse pluie
de sang en provenance du cratère en feu
de l'état voilà vont nous quitter le
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi naufrage d'un
voilier au large de perros-guirec quatre
jeunes scouts sont morts un plaisancier
des portés disparus l'imprudent sans
doute à l'origine de ce manque
tour de france richard virenque et huit
coureurs de l'équipe festina sont en
garde à vue ce soir interrogé par la
police la police qui a également
perquisitionné l'autel de l'église de
l'équipe paul lang est hollandaise tvm
qui elle est toujours sur le tout voilà
dans un instant la météo laurent romejko
demain soir ici même vous retrouverez
gérard leclerc je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre prochaine
bonsoir à lundi
oh